Google has long touted its open work
environment but that's not true instead
of creating a vibrant bloom of diverse
viewpoints political arguments are
ripping the company apart in heterodox
views our squelched last year James
d'amour was fired for daring to publicly
hold non liberal views they canned him
for that and yet even on the left Google
is turning into a contentious company in
January pro-animal Googlers invited PETA
co-founder Ingrid Newkirk to speak on
the Google campus but that appearance
was in the end next at the last minute
by a small even more left-wing caucus
within Google that argued that promoting
animal rights was somehow offensive to
human beings who face racism Kathy
Guillermo is a senior vice president at
PETA and she joins us and Kathy thank
you for coming on my pleasure thank you
so how we I want to take this argument
seriously to the extent it is a serious
argument
how does Peters position in favor of
animals denigrate human beings who face
racism well it doesn't at all that's
what's so silly about Google canceling
MS Newkirk speech what we're talking
about is compassion for everybody the
speech was about the roots of bigotry
and intolerance and how we need to be
compassion to everyone regardless of
species regardless of gender regardless
of race it's the most anti-racist speech
there could ever be was this surprising
to you I mean did you expect anything
like this reception at Google not at all
and I think what's so startling is the
bad manners on the part of Google
because Miz knew Couric was in the
parking lot she had flown to California
on her own expense and she's a very busy
person with a packed travel schedule she
is busy running campaigns so she came to
do this was delighted to speak to the
employees at Google who wanted to hear
her and what she had to say and as she
is literally stepping out of the car in
the Google parking lot she gets a phone
call saying that the speech has been
canceled without any explanation for why
that is and to this day they have yet to
tell them as Newkirk why the speech was
canceled well their Google we don't
to apologize have you heard this
argument before that being for animals
is is bigoted oh you know from people
who don't have very open minds yes but
it worries us when discourse is shut
down because the word racism might be
used in a speech if we're so sensitive
that we can't even listen to a talk that
talks about speciesism and racism and
compassion for all then I kind of worry
for our future there was no reason
whatsoever that people shouldn't have
heard her and anybody who disagreed with
her would have been welcome to say so at
the time you are old-fashioned if you
believe in the free exchange of ideas
but Google isn't just any other company
it's the choke point through which most
human information flows I mean Google
controls what we know about the world
should it worry us that they're
unwilling to hear any alternative
viewpoints well it should I think and I
also think that internally Google's in
quite a muddle this is a company that as
you point out delivers information and
yet they were not able to deliver us an
explanation for cancelling the speech
they have not called to reschedule it
and for people who know where we are
through our phones every minute of the
day they certainly are hard to reach
because we have tried contacting them
for the last four months and have met a
wall of silence amazing amazing thank
you for explaining what happened this
really says a lot about a lot appreciate
it thank you